ou est-ce qu'on est la maman chez pas
trop ma chérie
[Musique]
les voir
désolé d'en fait chez vous comme ça vous
avez de la veine j'ai soigné plus d'une
morsure par ici
je vais l'aider ça a l'air complètement
parieurs ça peut être du tout sens
dire qu'on a failli la perdre ce qui a
été fait pour votre fille a un certain
prix
son âme a aidé barnier vous devez
désormais en fournir une autre en
échange
sans quoi la sienne nous appartient ce
doit être fait avant le coucher du
soleil donc
vous avez intérêt à ne pas trop traîner
vous pouvez choisir l'âme que vous
voulez
mais ce doit être une âme humaine
vous apprêtez à tuer quelqu'un
je le vois dans vos yeux je t'aime
tellement tellement fort ma chérie